يزور قائد القوات البريه الروسيه
بيلاروسيا على راس لجنه عسكريه الروسيه
يصل اليك سيلكوب الى بيلاروسيا بصفته
نائبا للقائد الجديد للعمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا تقول وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان اللجنه تفقدت الوحدات العسكريه
الروسيه ضمن القوات الاقليميه المشتركه في
ميادين التدريب ببلا روسيا الزياره الاولى
للرجل بعد قرار موسكو تغيير قيادتها
العسكريه في الحرب قبل ايام قليله تم
تعيينه فاليري جرسيموف قائدا للقوات
الروسيه المشتركه في اوكرانيا يقول لك
كريم لان تجديد القياده مرتبط بتوسيع نطاق
مهام العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
الاهم في توقيت الزياره هو التدريبات
المشتركه المنتظره على الحدود الشماليه
الاوكرانيا ستعود مشاهد كهذه وتلك مناورات
القوه الروسيه والبيلاروسيه على الحدود
قبل ايام من اندلاع الحرب ستعود هذه
القوات بعد ايام قليله لتتدرب في الاجواء
البيلاروسيا
على الجانب الاخر من الحدود يجتمع الرئيس
الاوكراني بالمسؤولين العسكريين للبلاد
يترقبوا الجميع بحجر شديد مناورات الروس
مع البيلاروسين يتفقد قائد القوات
الاوكرانيه جنوده على الحدود مع بلاروسيا
لا يشكل الوضع الحالي على الحدود مع بلا
روسيا اي تهديد حتى الان لا مؤشرات على
عمليه بريه من الاعراض بلا روسيه ضد
اوكرانيا لكننا نتعامل بحذر ونراقب
باستمرار اي تطورات هناك نتصرف بهدوء انه
باحترافيه باستنادا الى المعلومات التي
نملكها ونزيد من التدريبات ونرفع قدراتنا
الدفاعيه هذا القلقله الاوكراني يتحول الى
منارات على الارض تنهي التدريبات
الاوكرانيه في الجبهه الشماليه هدوء استمر
لشهور وتعيد الى الاذهان مشاهد الهجمات
الروسيه انطلاقا من الاراضي البيلاروسيا
لتلك الاراضي صوره قاتمه في اذهان
الاوكرانيين في فبراير الماضي كانت مناوره
الروسيه البيلاروسيه هناك مجرده تمهيد
للهجوم الروسيه معا اندلاع الحرب فتح
المجال الجوي البيلاروسيه امام الطيران
والصواريخ الروسيه نحو اوكرانيا بعد شهرين
من اندلاع الحرب انطلقت مناورات الروسيه
بلا روسيه جديده وبعد ثمانيه اشهر اتفق
الرئيسان الروسي والبلروسي على انشاء قوات
اقليميه مشتركه وهذه القوه التي ستجرى
مناوراتها بعد ايام وعدت الى العاصمه
البيلاروسيه اخر اسبوع من العام الماضي ما
جدد المخاوف الاوكرانيه من دوري بيلاروسيا
في هذه الحرب